so there are three ways you can do sauna
that i can just toss out as like brief
things if you want to get a really big
growth hormone release for sake of
metabolism fat loss you're training
really really hard in jiu jitsu and you
want to recover
you don't want a sauna too often because
the study that um identified this
massive 16-fold increase in growth
hormone they had people do this it's
crazy
they got into okay temperatures are 80
to 100 degrees centigrade so that's 176
degrees fahrenheit to 212 degrees
fahrenheit
for 5 to 30 minutes
is the typical ranges that people work
in in these research studies
for maximum growth hormone
hormone release don't do sauna more than
once a week
but get into the sauna for 30 minutes
as hot as you can safely tolerate so
probably for you that'll be 210 because
you're i suspect you'll be on the high
end of things
then get out for five to ten minutes no
cold exposure get back in the sauna for
30 minutes then they had them do it
again out for five minutes back for 30
minutes out for five minutes back for
three minutes they had them do two hours
of sauna exposure to get that
growth hormone release
now for the
reduction in likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event stroke or otherwise
the more often you do sauna the better
so if you look at all calls all cause
mortality or death due to cardiovascular
events and you look at sauna use
frequencies using the same parameters 80
to 100 degrees centigrade
one to seven times per week basically
the more often you get into the sauna
for 30 minutes
across the week so 30 minutes a day is
better than four times a week four times
a week is better than two times a week
and two times a week is better than one
and
the reductions in mortality are really
impressive
27
if you get into the sauna the way i just
described not the two hours a day but 30
minutes
twice a week or three times per week you
reduce the likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event by 27
if you do it four or more times per week
you reduce the probability of dying by
50
of a cardiovascular event and in these
studies they rule out other things that
people are doing smoking they even ask
them do you live in an apartment are you
in a happy relationship like they
evaluate other potentially confounding
variables now for people that don't have
access to a sauna a hot water bath or
hot tub is going to be your next best
bet
and if you don't have access to that do
like the wrestlers do which is you know
put on two sets of
sweats and a hoodie and a stocking cap
and wrap yourself in plastics underneath
all that and go for a run but don't
please nobody die of hypothermia i mean
you can die of warming up too much is
this experience um
pleasant
or stressful
in the way so is it as stressful as an
ice bath okay great question
people always ask how cold to make the
ice bath or the cold water or the shower
you want it to be uncomfortably cold
meaning you want to feel like i really
want to get out but you can safely stay
in and that's going to vary by person
and experience with it experience yeah
with the sauna it's the same thing
how hot to make it well don't kill
yourself obviously
be smart if you're pregnant you
shouldn't be doing this anyway um
but
it's very clear that what you need is
the release of something called
dinorphin we have endorphin which makes
us feel good it binds to these mu opioid
receptors in the body you have dinorphin
which is the terrible feeling that you
get when you're in really hot
temperatures it's also the terrible
effect that alcoholics feel when they
are in withdrawal
you feel agitated you want to get out
it's really unpleasant it's dinorphin
binding to the so-called kappa opioid
receptor is that's what you're trying to
trigger when you do that a number of
things happen you set off heat shock
proteins that go repair
broken proteins and misfolded proteins
it also makes it so that later endorphin
binds its receptor more strongly so when
you have this uncomfortable experience
in the heat
you literally feel better in real life
when pleasurable vents come on
uh when you experience them in the same
way i like to say this that when you get
into a cold ice bath or cold shower the
increase in
epinephrine and dopamine is
two to three hundred percent these are
huge increases and they last many hours
this is shown
because lately i've been getting a
little bit of pushback on
twitter that which is you know um
interesting place um
people say well that's just in mice no
all the studies i just referred to are
all done in humans men and women fairly
broad age ranges so you want to be
uncomfortable in the cold you want to be
uncomfortable in the heat this is why
i'm not a big fan of infrared saunas
because they only go up to about 160 170
degrees
infrared light and far red light of all
kinds has been shown to be beneficial
for wound healing acne skin eyes there
are even guys now putting on their
testicles because it can increase
testosterone and sperm production yeah
hormone release hormone release but
in terms of the sauna you want that
strong heat stimulus yeah and that's
when you get crawl up to the 200 mark
and so on whenever i'm in new york and
there's also one in san francisco
although the one in san francisco is is
clothing optional just to warn people
there's a place called archimedes banya
is there any scientific evidence that
being naked is beneficial in the sauna
well in certain contexts it leads to um
childbirth okay i'll have to read up on
that i read that song but um
i suppose it's not required right for
childbirth but um but in all seriousness
you know in new york i'll go to a place
called spa 88 and actually uh khabib's
picture is on the wall he goes there and
it's a there that one it's clothing it
they require clothing i only just say
that because it can be a little bit of a
shock to people sometimes if they kind
of walk in there a bunch of naked people
the one in san francisco i if i go i'm
clothed mostly because you know i run
into co-workers or things like that you
know i i sort of more uh old-fashioned
in that way i suppose but um do you like
to wear clothes they're on co-workers
yes yeah in general yeah i mean just to
me it just seems like you know that just
be aware but but nonetheless the banjas
have very hot saunas because they're
russian owned and in new york there's
one on the lower east side but the spy
88 place they have some saunas that
the moment i get into those
i have a hard time catching a full
breath it burns they've got a cold dunk
that's like a shock and then they've got
a sauna a wet sauna steam room that's a
little mellower so the nice thing about
abanya is you can kind of find your
place and then they do the plaza where
they take the eucalyptus leaves and you
can pay someone and you basically you
cover your groin and then they beat you
with the the the leaves and it's
supposed to bring the vasculature to the
surface i've only done it once and
frankly i found it to be a little bit um
unnerving i didn't really like the
experience but i i'll try and get into a
sauna as often as i possibly can
which is you know once or three times
per week and i try and do the cold
exposure shower or immersion but early
in the day because it really wakes you
up one of my favorite
things i've listened to i wish there was
a video
is uh listening to a bunch of stuff with
rick rubin and um he did a thing with
tim ferriss like the tim ferriss podcast
i don't know if you've ever heard it but
he
he forced them to do they did the
podcast in a sauna
and i don't think at the time tim
ferriss was adapted yeah if you're not
heat adapted it can be pretty stressful
and i mean obviously the whole
experience is stressful as a somebody
with with microphones like what what is
happening but i just love
that tim was vulnerable enough to kind
of
give himself over to whatever the hell
this experience is and i
i'm just so happy that rick
like pushed that kind of idea and just
let's let's do it that's a very rick
rubin kind of thing to do and we must
not we like we must do this this has to
be done a podcast that was done from
asana continuously would be really
interesting like you could call it like
the pressure cooker or something oh i
mean like a regular pot yeah like yes
you have to sit with your guests in the
sauna um or they have to sit in the
sauna well that was one of the
interesting things is um
it was a sad thing because i believe
there's no video of that podcast but you
could tell
there was a kind of
there was suffering and especially
it was like a degradation
he he started over time not being able
to put words together correctly which
he's very eloquent and so you could see
there's like
there's a struggle heat and cold pull
you down from the inside you have to i
mean there's a reason why the screening
process for
um make you know sealed seal they call
it seal training but it's really
screening and training involves cold
waters because you know if you're in the
heat too long you'll die or damaged
tissue in cold you can do it quite
extensively before you die or damaged
tissue but it is stressful i was going
to say one thing that um
i sometimes enjoy seeing these social
media posts where people get into the
ice bath they'll look really stoic like
they're really tough
um but actually that's the wimpy way to
go through it
when you get into cold water if you stay
very still you develop a thermal
sheath around you
that you're warming yourself
the really bold way is to get in and
continue to sift your arms and legs and
it ends up feeling miserably colder
and there's no sheath because there's
you're breaking up them they're bringing
up that thermal layer and then when you
get out you'll notice a lot of people
huddle or they'll they'll put or they'll
grab the towel in general that's me i'll
get back i'll get into the sauna
but if you really want to stimulate the
big increases in metabolism
you stand out there and you dry off with
arms extended
in open air and as that water evaporates
off you it is really cold but your body
is forced to activate a number of the
warming programs related to metabolism
this is the beautiful work of a woman
named susannah soberg who's um
scandinavian she published this paper
last year in cell reports medicine and
so i call this the soberg principle
which is if you're doing ice and heat
for whatever reason it doesn't matter if
you end on heat or cold but if you're
using cold specifically to stimulate an
increase in metabolism end with cold
that's the sobering principle
and with cold yeah if you're alternating
and then
if you want to do it the tough way you
let the shivering so you just stand out
and let the water evaporate yeah i mean
if you ever waded into a cold ocean you
know everybody's kind of like holding
themselves you know if you really just
if you let yourself extend your limbs
and move them around a bit so you break
up that thermal layer
uh that's that's the tough way to do it
so when i see people on social media
getting in and they're like really tough
and trying to look hard yeah you want to
be moving around yeah
smiling talking moving around is way way
colder yeah yeah are you able to talk
can you do
so you suggest the podcast in the in the
sauna how about this i proposed this
since i got you you want to do the next
podcast i'll get two so the folks from
the plunge uh maybe could bring lexa a
plunge he certainly uh deserves one and
uh we can go side-by-side coffin style
or we can face one another
well we said we should do each other's
podcasts and maybe next year i can't
wait to have you back on i mean we only
scratched the surface well let's do at
least part of the next human lab podcast
either in the i have a sauna and a cold
plunge so we could do yeah yeah we could
do
in we do a sauna and a cold plunge
version i wonder the recording how the
recording works if there were a bit of
an echo in the sauna i'm sure we can
take out the reverb
you